who complained it complaint it
complained it listen to me you murmuring
and complaining you complaining and
complaining it could but shut up when
you truly decide it means you cut off
other options it means the excuses the
reasons the reasons right it can excuse
is that you have for why you can't
succeed suddenly vanish you will be more
successful if you make decisions based
upon what is going to feed your soul
rise and shine it's expresso time what's
up believe nation it seven my one word
is believe and I believe in you I
believe you have an amazing gift inside
you that I want to see explode out onto
the world so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message make a decision over
to you Eric Thomas you can't make a
difference until you make a decision you
better hear what I'm telling you man I'm
talking about the secret to success I'm
always telling you how I went from one
spot to the next spot and that was hit
right there listen to me catch the first
friend some oh you got it here you can't
make a difference until you make a
decision so for real some of you men you
keep crying you complain about your job
you complain about where you are
financially you complain about your
relationships you complain about your
opportunities you complaining
complaining complaining listen to me you
murmuring and complaining you
complaining and complaining kaput shut
up stop complaining and do me a favor if
you want to make a difference all you
got to do is one thing this side you can
start it you want some different listen
to me all you got to do is make a
decision that's it and for those of you
will be making the wrong decision all
you guys do is make the right decision
but if you want to make a difference
make a decision are you hearing what I'm
telling you what I'm trying to do for
you to take you to that next level
because I'm trying to give you control
of your life back some of you you ain't
got control you talking about your job
you got control let's
to me some of you talk about your
economics like you ain't got no control
you got a control I want you to know
that your life right now just sum total
in your decisions not your mama
decisions not your daddy listen to me
even if you made a decision you decided
to make their decisions so I need you to
me a favor I need you from this day
forward for the rest of your life make a
decision and I talk about again
something that I read I'm telling you
what I experienced
I remember being upset okay the word is
pissed off forgive me when the boss go
tell me I can't go see my daughter to
get her award you heard me say it before
it burned it burns she goes you can't go
see my daughter's getting an academic
award seven eight years old ain't
nothing like having your daddy in the
building and my boss telling me I can't
go so guess what I let it burn him and
one day I made a decision and I made a
decision to walk away and let me tell
you something I walked away and two
weeks later the video went viral when
you want to succeed as bad as you want
to breathe with vibro but it didn't go
viral and job made a decision the video
never went viral when I was complaining
it he'd never went by when I was
murmuring he never went by when I was
talking just to be talking but when I
made a decision to walk away when I made
a decision I when I made a decision to
follow my destiny I felt it calling me
my destiny was calling me and when I
decided to stop letting him call me but
I chased after her we went viable make a
decision nothing happens in your
business or in your life until you truly
decide that you want it and you may be
saying well Evan there's lots of things
I decided that I wanted to do that never
came true I decided I wanted to grow my
business I decided I wanted to be in a
relationship I decided I wanted to make
major strides and gains I decided I
decided I decided I'd never happened you
didn't decide you wished for something
you had a goal you had a dream you had a
desire but you didn't decide here's how
you know when you truly decide it means
you cut off other options
it means the excuses the reasons the
reasons write a que excuses that you
have for why you can't succeed suddenly
vanish really all those reasons are true
as well like they're legit reasons you
don't have enough time you don't have
enough money you don't
enough resources you don't have the
skill sets these are all logical
practical legit reasons for why you want
further ahead but once you've actually
decide that you're gonna make your mark
on a certain industry on a certain path
it's amazing how those excuses fall by
the wayside it's amazing how the path
starts to clear up and become open for
you a great example since you guys are
watching my youtube channel when I was
doing my YouTube I did a little bit here
and there I was making videos I made
stuff I was proud of but it was start
and stop and start and stop I was really
just experimenting with the platform I
hadn't fully committed to it and then
when I connected with my agent in New
York he gave me the assignment of
redoing my bio video my origin story why
I do what I do why is it so important to
me and I told the story to guys a number
of times in the channel but he had me
doing it three times a day
I do it in the morning and he would give
me feedback and I'd reshoot it at lunch
and they'd give me feedback and I'd
reshoot it again in the evening he'd
give me more feedback and so three times
a day I would be making and this were
like 20 30 minute long videos it wasn't
just the two-minute quick introduction
piece I did it again and I did it again
and I did it again and if you had asked
the Evan a month prior to say Evan what
I need you to do is commit to be able to
make three videos that will take you you
know an hour and a half to three hours
every single day that's what you need to
do to move forward with us I would've
said you're crazy
I don't know that I don't have the time
for that I can't I can't fit the time in
there I can't do that I've got other
responsibilities that's gonna take up
too much I can't do that right that
would be my reason aka an excuse and
this is how I was able to get better
because once I decided that this was
important to me that I wanted to improve
as a speaker that I wanted to get better
as a storyteller that I really wanted to
boost my presence as a brand as an
authority as a youtuber that I really
cared about it once I made that decision
suddenly the time excuse suddenly
disappeared where did it go
I don't know I made the time I found the
time and when I started with my agency I
was the worst I almost wasn't allowed in
I didn't have enough of a voice I wasn't
a good
speaker at the beginning and he took a
flyer on me and then within a month of
doing those videos and getting better I
quickly became the best practice I
quickly became the example for all the
other people at the agency to look to
when I started off as being the worst
why because I was doing the three videos
a day when they had a hard time finding
time to do a video a week making one
video a week is so difficult you know
it's gonna take me three hours what do I
find the three hours to do that I've got
a business to run on and a family and
responsibilities and all these other
projects I don't have the time to commit
more than two or three hours a week to
make a video and that's why they stayed
at a certain level and me starting from
scratch having zero skills poor content
you know poor understanding Dane was
able to quickly pass them and become the
best process example that was being
shared because I decided they didn't
decide and I did and this is your
strength this is your power I share this
story because I'm not a genius or a
natural talent you can win too you have
the same level or better skills than I
do at what you do you can win when you
decide that it's important enough to you
when you decide to put in the time when
you decide to throw away the excuses
when you decide to not listen to all the
rationale and the people around you
saying wow you're working so hard no
you're not you're not working hard
enough you didn't decide that it's
important enough to you when other
people let you off the hook you don't
let yourself off the hook so if you set
a goal and you look at it and you say
that's a great goal I would love to do
that I'm very motivated by it and the
first things that then pop into your
head are all the reasons why you can't
do it then you haven't truly decided my
strong urge for you is I want you to
move from the place of just having hopes
and wishes and goals and dreams
those are great but I want you to move
from that place to the place where
you've decided that one of those things
are gonna happen it's a priority it's
important for you for your family for
your community for your cut
it's important you decided you're gonna
be world-class at this thing go make it
happen now I've got a special bonus tip
for you but before getting to that I
want to know what have you decided
recently maybe watching this video maybe
you're leading up to it and the research
that you're doing but what what have you
decided that this has to happen in your
life or in your business there was no
other option this has to happen what
have you decided
leave it down in the comments below I
really want to find out thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love we'll see you tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso and enjoy
the bonus clips
[Music]
another would be and I don't know if
you've ever had any interaction with
Kyle Maynard Kyle Maynard's fascinating
guy he's that he was born a congenital
quad amputee so he is his arms and
before the elbows and his legs before
the knees nonetheless he is in the
National Wrestling Hall of Fame like
collegiate wrestling and is the first
person to ever climb Mount Kilimanjaro
without prosthetics so he military
crawled the entire nose he's such a stud
and he was taught by a CEO at one point
the CEO used this for hiring but you can
use it for anything
this particular CEO very successful
would have his current employees rank
prospective employees from one to ten
and that's not interesting by itself his
rule was you can't use seven so I want
you to hang from one to ten
you can't answer seven and what what
ends up being so beautiful about that
and leveraged is that seven is a safe
number it's kind of like the non
offensive Switzerland of answers it's
not committal it's not too bad so you
can wiggle out of it whereas if you're
choosing a six that's barely passing
that's not good if it's an eight you're
indicating you are pretty stoked like
you're vouching force them to make a
decision exactly so you can love it one
to ten no seven and so I've used that
and kylus used it for say invitations
anything imitation to conferences
invitations to coffee whatever it might
be it's like decisions in life decisions
in life
do not make any decisions based on money
none it's the worst way to make a
decision which I know is so hard to say
I mean I didn't grow up with any money
and I know so many of us are our
families have a lot at stake they put a
lot into us made a lot of sacrifices for
us and you say you don't have the luxury
of doing that but I actually think you
do you will be more successful if you
make decisions based upon what is going
to feed your soul make you feel value
valued validated you know have you
waking up in the morning and we're
seeing to work whatever it might be and
I can tell you after a short amount of
time money will not be enough at the end
of the day a bigger paycheck
is another suit or more real estate more
square footage that's what it comes down
to you end up with another room and a
fuller closet and after a while that's
not gonna do it the one thing that
Forest Whitaker said to you as you were
shooting everybody stuck with you there
was something worse they're so nice
where's one on people he doesn't talk a
whole lot in everything you said is
really important everything moving I
think that I think there's number one
thing you told me was talk talk so
always always makes it make the best
decisions that you can make in the
moment he's honest and that's all you
can that's all you can ever do and I
think he was referring to to take on the
pressures that surround us around money
making a film based on a true story
making a film is that that's said in the
area where air is taking place making
the film you don't have a lot of
resources no making a phone with sort of
a short schedule you just you just told
me I don't make the best decisions you
can display this basically and then move
on raise your standard Apple at the cool
it's core value is that we believe that
people with passion and not one drop of
most self-worth depends on Europe it's
supposed to mean I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or completely
incapacitated hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top ten
Rose a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details